all right finally this is a report for
the daily wire
it's this one's getting a lot of
attention former backup dancers for
lizzo filed a lawsuit on Tuesday against
the singer in her production company
alleging sexual harassment and a toxic
work environment
in a lawsuit obtained by People magazine
and filed in Los Angeles Superior Court
against the 35 year old singer born
Melissa Jefferson
the three backup dancers are suing lizzo
her production company big girl big
touring that's
g-r-r-r-l big tourings that's the name
of the company big girl big touring and
lizzo's dance team captain Charlene
Quigley
the three dancers Ariana Davis Krista
Williams and Noel Rodriguez in the suit
alleged that lizzo pressured them to
engage with nude performers at an
Amsterdam Club in February of 20 2023.
according to the AP lizzo began inviting
cast members to take turns touching the
nude performers during the sexually
themed show in Amsterdam Amsterdam's red
light district the good as hell hitmaker
allegedly led a chant pressuring Davis
to touch the breasts of one of the new
women performing at the club despite the
dancer expressing her desire not to
touch the performer people noted
the complaint States finally the course
began became overwhelming and a
mortified Miss Davis acquiesced in an
attempt to bring an end to the chance
plaintiffs were aghast with how little
regard lizzo showed for the bodily
autonomy of her employees and those
around her especially in the presence of
many people whom she employed another
part of the filing reads quote things
quickly got out of hand lizzo began
inviting cast members to take turns
touching the new performers and
interacting with objects launched from
the performers
and then there's a lot of other so it's
getting into details we probably don't
need
um and uh then they also allege other
things as well they say that uh they're
that the rehearsals were very long 12
hours is excruciating they're being
worked like slaves they say and there
was also uh
inappropriate conversations that went on
and now I'm just summarizing
they ironically they claim that lizzo
fat shamed
well there's a lizzo fat shamed one of
the dancers and said that she needs to
lose weight
and other things as well
I'm just
I'm shocked I'm flabbergasted I mean
I
there's
there's no way you're telling me lizzo
did all of this
you're accusing lizzo of being a deviant
of being a pervert of being disgusting
and inappropriate
I can't believe it
you're accusing big girl big touring Inc
of cultivating an inappropriate work
environment
I don't believe it
that that doesn't sound like the big
girl big touring ink that I know
that's not the big girl big touring ink
that I worked for okay
I just can't believe any of this
I mean you're telling me that lizzo
along with her company big girl big
touring Inc
they went to a sex show in Amsterdam
with all their dancers and inappropriate
things happened
unbelievable if you're hiring you're
probably dealing with economic
uncertainty and now more than ever it's
important to hire the right people
faster and more efficiently to keep
overall costs down well thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner who is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
ZipRecruiter does is for you right now
you can try them for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh ZipRecruiter
smart technology identifies the best
matches for you and your job and lets
you invite candidates that you really
want to apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love how
their pricing is really straightforward
you can stick to your budget without any
surprises at all hire the best with the
help of a partner who's all about you
with ZipRecruiter four out of five
employers who post on simply could get a
quality candidate within the first day
you got to go to this is what exclusive
web address to try ZipRecruiter for free
that's ziprecruiter.com Walsh again
that's ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
you know what I always say is that if
you're going to go with your colleagues
to a sex show in Amsterdam you got to
make sure that things are very
appropriate the whole time you got to
respect boundaries respect those those
boundaries while you're at the sex show
in Amsterdam
um
so of course like there's there really
isn't any victim here this is really no
one to root for in this thing I mean you
you went to you're in Amsterdam and you
went to the red light district to a sex
show
with your boss did you think things
would be like what boundary all the
boundaries are obliterated already so
walk it in the doors like no one should
be there in the first place
um and I also just don't I don't have a
lot of sympathy oh they were chanting
and they told me so just leave
just leave
but it's not right assuming all this
happened I don't know if it happened or
not uh and all joking aside all of this
sounds exactly like what I would expect
every part of this is like oh yeah well
that's
you're on tour with lizzo this is
exactly what I assumed happened
um
so
if the allegations are true and they
were chanting and they were being
pressured to touch the performers that's
very wrong and gross and bad
and also
you're an adult and you're in that
situation you shouldn't have gone in the
first place just leave
I didn't know to do they were chanting
at me so
they were chanting at you so you can't
just leave leave immediately you know
it's a lot more compelling to me
if well if you don't go in the first
place but even if you go
and then uh and and this all happens
you're being pressured to engage in like
sexual activity essentially and
and you refuse like an adult and you say
I'm not going to do that
and you leave and then you immediately
go and tell people what happened
you say this is what I just experienced
I left the situation this is wrong
but when you do the thing and then
months later you come out and say I was
really uncomfortable with that well
all that means is like there's just
blame to go around for everyone no one's
a good guy in this everyone's just hard
there's a bunch of horrible deviant
disgusting perverts essentially that's
my uh that is my that's my judgment of
all of this and it's not a surprise
of course
um even though lizzo has her whole brand
about body positivity and respecting
people and all of that
of course that's all nonsense
or rather
maybe I wouldn't say it's nonsense it's
very narrow okay when she talks about
body positivity and respecting people
and all these things
she means in a very narrow sense
in that it only pertains to her
it's all about her so she wants you to
be positive about her body and she she
wants you to be respectful of her
because all that matters is her it is
all focused on her that's all she
doesn't care about anybody else
obviously
still I'm wondering if we're supposed to
believe all women
what do we do here like who how do we
navigate this one believe all women
because we believe all of them I guess
that's what we're left with
everybody's right turns out if you'd
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed